us joining us now and i'm delighted he's
with us kevin mccarthy
of course the house minority leader uh
he will join us uh
now and congressman mccarthy i don't
think
retaking the house is a pipe dream
anymore i thought it was a few months
ago but not anymore
it's not do you know that there are
fewer democrats in the house since nancy
pelosi held the gavel
at that moment we needed 19 seats to win
the majority today we only need
17. we won every special election we
played in
and that was in democrat seats that
democrats won by more than nine points
and it happened to be in california
the real question is what are the
results of the democrats they should be
embarrassed of how much they have
embraced the socialist
name me one problem this democrat
majority has solved
there isn't one but you know what the
republicans have done we rolled out a
commitment to america
all you have to do is go
commitmenttoamerica.com
you could see for yourself we are going
to rebuild
the biggest economy we have ever seen
add 10 million new jobs
we're going to restore our way of life
you know what we're going to do
we're going to end covet because we're
going to create a safe
and effective vaccine we protect
pre-existing conditions
you know what we don't defund the cops
we add 1.75 billion
to make more police training community
policing and more importantly
500 000 body cameras congress
yes congressman let me just jump in here
when is the last time you had a
substantive
in-depth conversation with nancy pelosi
about
anything you know i i've i'm around her
many times in many meetings but i can't
say i have a
substance talk with her in more than a
year think for one moment
yesterday we watched world peace happen
for the middle east
on this on the steps inside the white
house you know what nancy pelosi did she
turned down the invitation and she held
votes in the floor of the house
trying to make members not go there and
witnesses
represent and acknowledge israel all
right so congratulations
for years congressman i want to get to
your reaction again breaking news uh
just reported by politico fox news has
now confirmed it
that the freedom caucus is pressing you
to launch long
shot bid to oust her on nancy pelosi
it's a procedural gambit
has virtually no chance of success but
it could force vulnerable democrats to
align with the speaker
ahead of the election congressman
explain this are you in favor of it
well what i'm in favor of is defeating
nancy pelosi and nadler and all the
others
if if we were able to remove nancy
pelosi you'd have another democrat
the real challenge would be we're four
weeks away from election for
40-some days these democrats could
actually
vote against nancy pelosi use it in
their campaigns
to say they're not with her even though
they vote with her 95 percent of the
time
because she doesn't need all the votes
so you're not going to have another
majority
are you going to do that or not i don't
think it's the best move at this moment
i think the best move has win 218 seats
and
that defeats nancy pelosi but you know
what else it defeats nadler
maxine waters adam schiff and the others
that is our best play right now
do you agree with me that there's really
two things at play
one which all of you do you need to
raise money two
for when you're democrat and you're kind
of in you you thought you were a
moderate
you're just petrified of getting
primaried by the aoc
plus three and so you're you you're
caught between raising money from the
establishment pelosi
and not getting primaried so you
basically just shut up
i mean yeah you've watched aoc primary
and beat people
this year they are all afraid aoc is the
one
who got pelosi to impeach do impeachment
because she went out starting primary
people for them to do that there was no
basis for it
that's what they wasted their majority
on when you look at the democrat
majority what have they stood for
defunding of the police dismantling of
this nation
because they want to go within open
borders open borders
and you know what they want to do they
pretty much want to destroy us because
they want to raise taxes on the very
first day
regardless of where this economy is at
they haven't built any new jobs
they haven't lowered the drug price they
haven't made this country better so you
know if
if you renew this nation you rebuild the
biggest economy
you restore our way of life you know
what happens you reunite this nation
and that's exactly what the commitment
to america is all about